I just want to have fun at Disney I
don't want to worry about things being
plastic free Z Rosi Rosi Z zero we're
gonna go to Disneyland and try to be
zero waste Cooper I've been to
Disneyworld 23 times I go every single
year with my family I am
Mickey's top ho it's mommy and mommy
we're taking Joyce to Disney movies you
ready yes I forgot my collapsible Cup
did you bring any cups or any reuse of
those things you know what I will go
back for in the more well we'll see how
this year
we're at the Disneyland park on Main
Street so we can eat our you suppose
their waist at the park
our friends Paris on matchbox kitchen
did a blog where two entities in zero
waste were following to her
recommendations tank let's go I have our
own napkins so don't grab any mail we're
like getting full-service treatment here
to the plaza
[Music]
besides tomatillo
last time I went to Disney none of the
places would refill my reusable water
bottle and a lot of the water fountains
were really spaced out so I have these
water bottles and it's hot in Florida I
can't not drink water on the Millennium
Falcon I give it to you violet
yeah - to navigate engineers the current
achievement
[Applause]
we didn't really May we successfully do
that mission yeah yeah
for helping me to work I love how all
the trashes are designed for the
different lands we love a multi-faceted
trash so this year Disney eliminated
plastic straws plastic stirs and
styrofoam I think that's super cool
because when they think about it it's
like millions stops we don't need to
worry about me than trash today
we're getting really thirsty so we're
gonna refill our bottles at the regular
water fat hands trained me ha
because they serve there
eating our lunch looking good all zero
waste
I'm impressed with the plant-based
options because I've been able to be
vegetarian all day long and you learned
that all the restaurants that Disneyland
send all their food wastes from the
animal feeding plan in tomorrow and
today and tomorrow and future space and
time and stuff I really want some hard
candy but it's wrapped in a big old
piece of pasta do you not get it now cuz
we zero waste over here bye bye
so we using
my paper don't come no more paper number
problem water refill station tomorrow
and spooky
I'm sorry
[Music]
when I usually go to Disneyland with my
family the first thing we do is get a
turkey leg this nice turkey legs are
fired yeah this is a juicy turkey leg oh
it's cool
paper bag I had to get ice cream
but just a little
some paper I've included pretty good
[Music]
[Music]
that's better probably fine